a 500 detox of just like straight up
powder no this has gone too far hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
today I'm going to be talking about the infamous
500 all powder detox diet and I'm going to be
recreating said detox with actual food for a
hell of a lot less hit up my description for
my disclaimer as well as a link to my free
Hunger crushing combo ebook and my ltk page
where you can look at what I'm wearing this week
okay so I recently had a viral Tick Tock where I
reviewed another Creator's 500 5 day detox from
a brand called chroma Wellness not surprisingly
I was a little shook by the whole premise of
spending 500 on powders for only five days of
your life and was left with a lot of questions
so naturally I did a deep dive so you never ever
ever will have to let's get to it first of all do
you need to spend 500 on a detox no if you're new
here welcome but let it be super clear that you
do not need anything to detox your body if you're
breathing peeing and pooping congratulations you
are detoxing so really all you got to do is get
in that water some Fiber a little movement that is
all that you need to get your natural detox organs
aflo in so yeah we could just shut this BS all
down right now but that would probably upset the
hardcore detox community so let's take a closer
look at the chroma detox itself now according to
their website this reset allegedly helps with
overall slimming and deep loading better sleep
and clear mind weight loss of course more energy
balanced adrenals increased metabolism function
and improved digestion their elevator pitch was
that the reset would help you re-establish healthy
habits with functional Whole Foods and beverages
which is a little ironic considering it looks
like a Rolodex of colorful packets of powder
but I detector tests determined that was a lie
they also say that they believe that
eating healthy should be pleasurable
is not adding up right here and I'm gonna
show you why so Carla has three different
five-day protocols lifestyle lean and active their
lifestyle is allegedly their most popular which
they say will result in an average weight loss
of four pounds their lean program is even more
restrictive which I did not think was possible
but for the record folks if you lose four pounds
in five days on this cleanse it is simply because
you're consuming very little real food and taking
like a ton of diuretics and laxatives this is
not fat loss it is water loss and yes you will
immediately gain it all back not sure that's
a great Roi that said let's see what we get
to eat and how we can make it a lot cheaper
okay step one of the program is to break the
fast so you're supposed to fast for like 12 to 16
hours to stimulate fat burning I've talked a lot
about the problem with this statement right here
but yeah I guess I naturally fast like 12 to 13
hours just based on what normally feels good
to my body and when I feel hungry so I guess
we're already on track with that when you wake
up you are then allowed to have their adaptogenic
beauty matcha with either water or any kind of
non-dairy unsweetened milk and the ingredients
here do actually look pretty good we got collagen
protein we got matcha we got adaptogens lots of
clear benefits here um and what we know is that
l-theanine and egcg in the matchup plus the
adaptogenic mushrooms will help to give you a more
slow energy release compared with the rise and
fall that you would get from something like coffee
and I'm going to say that the ginger in there is
probably to help with digestion the problem is
we have no idea how much we're getting of any
of these ingredients it's just a proprietary blend
so it very well could all be like window dressing
in very non-clinical dosages regardless of the
claim I can get on barbas matcha but still it's
not a detox so for actual breakfast they give you
this packet of what they call Super porridge which
apparently you're allowed to eat with some berries
if you want um the porridge itself based on the
ingredient list is made up of really nutritious
ingredients so almond meal different seeds oats
some plant-based protein flax like it really is
a pretty super porridge with lots of fiber and
healthy fats in there the fiber specifically
might benefit regularity which would probably
help with their digestion claims but seeing
as weight loss is such a strong promise with
krona I would have expected more than just like 10
grams of protein since we do have ample research
to support a high protein breakfast for weight
loss so I'm going to make my own protein super
porridge here which has like three times as much
protein and is way cheaper to make step one oats
hemp high protein milk I'm gonna let that simmer
until it Cooks through a little and for some
protein I've got some egg whites I'm just whisking
until nice and fluffy now we're just gonna fold in
the egg whites what does that mean
he folds it in your arm workout
I got a super ripe banana I'm gonna Mash that in
you turn the heat off pop on a lid and let
it sit uninterrupted for like three minutes
of super porridge I'm gonna add a little bit of
almond butter on top yum and some fresh berries
and if you're wondering if this tastes eggy
literally just ask the thousands of people
who have made it for my blog and my cookbook
it literally tastes like a cloud super high in
protein we got lots of healthy fats we've got lots
of fiber it is one of my all-time favorite meals
brutal
Santa Buddies For Life right rough day out there
perfect day for some porridge so their next step
is hydration so they have this cranberry hydration
Elixir as they call it um which you're allowed to
sip throughout the day as needed or post-workout
so this is like an electrolyte drink it's made
with coconut water cranberry ginger and cayenne
I'm assuming the cranberry is just to add some
flavor and vitamin C um the coconut water adds
a little bit of electrolytes like magnesium and
potassium for a hydration system this literally
offers nowhere near the clinical dosages for
electrolytes the only reason that I can see for
the addition of the ginger and the Cayenne is
to make you poop which I mean I guess is how they
sell it as a detox but yeah I'm gonna take a pass
at that since I literally got the same amount of
magnesium and even more potassium just from the
banana that I add added to my oats in a lot of
cases water is more than enough moving on is the
Boost I love the names I really do um so we get
a smoothie and there's a few different flavors
to choose from there's also so little sodium in
this day so far like even with the addition of
the electrolyte powder you might look slightly
less puffy but all of that would immediately
return to normal the moment you ate real food
and you'd also feel like complete so let's
make an actual chocolate banana smoothie that
doesn't suck top secret chocolate protein powder
milk I'm using the higher protein
milk which I love a real banana
that's not just like dehydrated banana
powder a little bit of peanut butter
and to add some extra micronutrients and fiber
I've got some ran bits of cooked broccoli here
oh yeah baby
um
that is so good way more protein plus fiber
and healthy fats and a hell of a lot cheaper
to make cheers finally it's lunch time and
you think at this point you'd get to like
chew something but no you literally get powdered
broth just powder and not even the good stuff
oh I blew it but like honestly for something worth
500 you are seriously eating like post-apocalyptic
End of the World style I do not understand
this anyway I assume the point of this is
to a keep calories as low as possible seeing
as there's only 80 calories in this lunch and
B to heal the gut with the bone broth base
now in short I'm actually a big fan of bone
broth I love it mainly because I think it's a
really good high protein base for soup but we
also do have some early lab studies suggesting
that the unique amino acids in bone broth like
collagen gelatin Glycine and glutamine may help
to strengthen the gut barrier and to soothe gut
inflammation but the funny thing about this
particular product is that I actually see a
lot of high FODMAP ingredients in this base so
like onion garlic chives which probably make
it taste a lot better but may also exacerbate
IBS symptoms like bloating and gas honestly
at this point the whole powdered food thing is
kind of like freaking me out what freaking out
so let's upgrade this like a
million fold step one bone broth
and then literally whatever vegetables
I have in the fridge I got some bell
peppers some snap peas and
some already roasted carrots
all right add in some chicken and some
chickpea noodles that I've pre-cooked the
thing that anyone would try to sell you powdered
broth over this is mind-blowing but we have way
more nutrition going on we have all the benefits
of the bone broth but we also have benefits
from all the veg the fiber rich noodles and the
chicken oh and I added in some sourdough because
the detox if you can boil water and put it into
powder you can also definitely do this okay so
after lunch it's time for the fuel phase where
basically you get Cronus version of ag1 which is
called their super green Elixir not unlike ag1
it's basically like a laundry list proprietary
blend of everything expensive vegetable and
extract Under the Sun so I do see some adaptogens
I see some digestive enzymes some probiotics green
tea aloe vera Etc which are all really great and
possibly are very helpful but I also see a ton
of fodmaps here which I just do not get apple
fiber cauliflower broccoli stem kale artichoke
Leaf like these are some of the highest FODMAP
sources this could be like Napalm for your bowels
if you have IBS and listen I have no qualms with
greens powders I actually think that they're a
simple source of micronutrients if you're like on
the go or maybe you just don't get a lot of those
nutrients in they're literally a flavored powdered
multivitamin which I love but they're not a
substitute for real vegetables like you literally
have less than a gram of fiber per serving and I
assume there's a need to get more micronutrients
in this diet because there is so little actual
nutrition in this day but in my case with all
the meal tweaks that I've made I'd say it's like
completely obsolete so we can move on next is
their snack time which sadly is also not chewable
it's another latte but this one actually does
sound delicious so we got adaptogenic mushrooms
and ashwagandha which we do have research to
support its use for anxiety blood sugar regulation
and fitness just to name a few benefits so I am
totally into incorporating something like this
into my afternoon ritual but again this is not a
detox like I'm pretty sure in the context of this
day this is just a low calorie distraction from
your actual hunger and since I've been eating all
day again I can probably pass on said snack now
the next phase is the energy protein snack not to
be confused with the other snack which was just
a latte so this is their oh my God cookie butter
but it does sound like it's the best part of this
detox because you actually get to chew something
that would be a hell of a lot better on some bread
so it's basically a combination of different nut
Butters oil hemp protein powder and sugars it's
got 110 calories per tablespoon 4 grams of carbs
and three grams of protein again for an alleged
energy protein snack there is neither a lot of
energy nor protein in this so I'm going to do
my version that won't cost 25 per jar and I'm
gonna be a rebel and I'm gonna put it on some
thank you
foreign the thought of having
to eat just a spoonful of nut
butter as my only chewable meal of the
day is giving mad Kelly Ripa Vibes and
that is my first chewable food of the but
this my friends is how you eat nut butter
the crunch Factor Protein healthy fats fiber
definitely the best part of the day I will say
that but I'm not super hungry right now so
I'm going to save this for my final meal so
dinner is again another sachet of broth yay
so this time we are allowed to add a little
bit of veggies or protein which I already
took the liberty of doing in round one so
I'm just gonna finish off the batch that I
made earlier and call it a boring food day
um at least my snack is interesting so I can enjoy
that you guys always hear me say that varieties of
spice of life and it's so important that we're
getting a variety of different foods in our diet
not just for micronutrient diversity but also for
gut microbiome diversity that says nobody has to
make a whole different meal every single day
every day of the week I don't I love leftovers
why would I cook twice or three times when I can
cook once and just get the job done healthy eating
shouldn't be complicated and it definitely
doesn't need to be an exorbitant amount of
work or cost a lot of money so variety can also
look like choosing carrots and broccoli on one
week and then having peas and parsnips the next
it's all about the bigger picture and the long
game not the minutia of every single meal or every
single day still just as good as it was at lunch
all right step 529 after dinner so post dinner
you get a sachet of their magnesium supplement
which is supposed to help calm the Mind soothe
the muscles and support the digestive system so
I can see from their information that they use
a magnesium blend which is actually pretty smart
since different forms of magnesium have different
uses in the body so the citrate is a laxative so
I assume that again supports their detox Mo the
gluconate is sometimes used for sleep but really
the chelated version glycinate is much better
in my opinion and the Magnesium acetyl tarnate
is mostly study for heart health but it may have
some potential for stress TBD really the problem
is just that based on the total magnesium
blend it's not nearly enough for a clinical
dosage like you're way better off just buying a
magnesium supplement from your drugstore in the
specific form that you need and just taking that
especially since the inulin root in this blend
might again egg bloating and gas like I just
don't get that piece but anyways that's what
I do I take magnesium visclicity because I don't
need a laxative every night I just really want
to sleep better and this actually helps me if
you're wondering when this hellish day can end
congratulations we are finally here the last stage
is back to fasting naturally so at the end of
the day you're supposed to have this perfect fast
Ginger turmeric detox and calming tea to allegedly
curb the urge to late night snack naturally it's
literally just Ginger turmeric Licorice and some
other herbs and spices and yes Ginger does have
some Pro kinetic properties meaning that it can
kind of help to support normal bowel motility and
function but again if this tea does anything to
help you detox it's just by helping you drink more
water which makes you pee which as we established
is your body's way of detoxing naturally it's
also again a distraction from the fact that
you have eaten so very little for five days so
yeah a non-caffeinated tea is a great way to end
the day but it's not a detox so to summarize it
blows my mind how much people pay for so little
actual food like this detox provides 850 calories
a day like you're spending a hundred dollars for
less than a thousand calories of food let that
sink in so yeah the reason why you might look
slimmer or actually see a temporary drop on the
scale is because you're starving and you've just
taken a ton of laxatives and diuretic supplements
all day if you're really desperate to drop water
weight like this you might as well just take an
over-the-counter laxative for twenty dollars and
like spend your days on the toilet not that I'm
recommending people ever do that but it would
literally do the same thing so folks please
please be wary of these overpriced overhyped
detox programs with beautiful marketing like it
is beautiful but it's a waste of money at best
and it's dangerous at worst definitely not Abby
approved save your money and go buy my cookbook
Shameless plug I don't know about
that I have for you guys today
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on what you'd like to see me do next
subscribe to the channel don't forget to
hit up my description for my free Hunger
crushing combo ebook and I'll see you
next time on Abby's kitchen bye foreign